hey youtubers it's Charlie you guys
requested a special flash Theory video
for the finale so remember this is all
theory stuff to try to avoid rampant
spoilers so here we go the thesis of the
finale is that the TV show is going to
try to inflict maximum emotional damage
on you without breaking what the show is
who the comic book characters are like
it'll still be the flash when we get to
season four but they still have to drop
a body in despite what you've seen
nobody actually knows who the person who
dies is but I have a pretty good theory
based on the evidence we've seen so far
in some of the tricks that the show is
pulls in the past so I'll try to explain
all that there is a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so there are a
couple important things to remember
we'll talk around this a little bit just
to avoid rampant spoilers because
there's still an element of speculation
but there is a way to logically explain
how the flash show stays the flash like
they don't fundamentally alter the core
of what the flash character is and they
still drop a body in the finale because
greg berlanti who's kind of like the s--
avatar in real life for all the DC shows
he's sort of like the god for all the CW
DC stuff that's going on he said the key
to ratings in the time of peak TV is a
dead body but not the body you expect
there's already enough evidence to say
that it's not going to be iris West
because that would fundamentally alter
what's going on with the flash character
and even though they change a lot of
minor details like the twist with hunter
zolomon becoming zoom pretending to be
Jake Gary savatage costume looking like
this they're still very true to who the
characters are in iris West is just like
a fundamental part of who the Barry
Allen character is in the comics but
based on all the evidence we have so far
I don't think iris West is going
anywhere but everybody's been talking
about funeral photos so there is a body
being dropped there is somebody that's
in the casket it's going to be this big
emotional twist for the characters
so let's deleted the question about what
Barry is going to do about Savitt are
the big twist about how somebody has to
be stuck in the Speed Force like he
sucks avatar in there whence avatar
escape Jay Garrick had to take his place
they have to resolve that big plot point
they have to completely resolve what
happened during flashpoint now the
reverse-flash went back and killed
Barry's mother but
there's a really important thing that's
missing from this scene so I'm going to
play these clips starting with the
season 1 finale where Barry goes back
the first time ending with the season 3
premiere where he tries to quote-unquote
fix flashpoint although I don't think
that he actually fixed it
so you watch the season 1 finale and you
see the future version of berry with a
white emblem telling season 1 berry
don't do it don't save your mother
everything is fixed he prevents some big
catastrophe we know that that becomes
flashpoint that this future flash is
trying to prevent so berry goes back we
see this moment then by the end of
season 2 he walks that back and says you
know what I can't handle this
I just lost my father I'm going to go
back and save my mother and he creates
flashpoint when he stops reverse-flash
the important thing that we don't see in
this scene is the other future version
of berry talking to the season 1 version
of berry so that's nowhere in this scene
here and then when we jump to the season
3 premiere and we get the resolution to
flashpoint or what we think is supposed
to be the resolution to that we also do
not see a version of this scene here
with the future berry telling the berry
from season 1 don't save your mother
that could mean one of two things one
it's a glaring continuity error and they
just chose not to include it and they've
already fixed flashpoint we'll never go
back to that moment to the other option
is is that berry will try to go back and
we'll see the resolution to this this
actual moment they're really good about
paying things like that off which is why
I think at some point in the future we
will actually see this moment from this
berries perspective and not from the
season one various perspective but just
remember every once in a while there are
glaring continuity errors one of the
interesting ways that they try to
sidestep that is the way Jay Garrick
explains berry fracturing time-space
when he time travels like every time you
try to time-travel crit you crack the
coffee cup time breaks in a way that
you're not capable of fixing so that's
just implying that he'll never be able
to fully erase what happened during
flashpoint so that's how you get to like
future versions of killer frost being on
the team like she can be killer frost
they won't completely change that she'll
never go back to being the non-meta
version of Caitlin but it also means
that even if he does go back and try to
do this that it won't completely erase
avatar he will have to fight him in to
beat him and even Savitt are talked
about having knowledge pre flashpoint
like he waited for flashpoint to happen
to seize his opportunity so whatever
your Savitt are theories are he predates
all
of this stuff but the big thing the body
being dropped that's the really
important thing that everybody's
wondering about the evidence from behind
the scenes seems to suggest that most of
the main characters will pretty much all
the main characters are going to survive
in some fashion they'll be fundamentally
altered but it's not like they're going
anywhere
so Tom Cavanagh Julian like all the big
characters that you love the new comic
book characters they've introduced will
be able to return in some way that
doesn't mean they will return it just
means the actors are capable of coming
back logically and playing versions of
their characters but the big theory here
the person that I think is in the casket
is actually the most important person in
iris West life like think about this
what is Barry stuck on he's stuck on his
parents dying who's the most important
woman in his life not iris I mean you
think it'd be iris because they just got
engaged it's actually his mother so
who's the most important man in iris
Westlife it's not Barry even though they
also just got engaged it's her father
Joe West so this is a theory that would
still allow the flash TV show to
fundamentally be the comic book version
of the TV show you'd see all the normal
things that you would see if you were
reading the comic book all the crazy
villains all the new heroes that you've
met like gypsy just a totally awesome
character Joe West is not really a comic
book character so you can get rid of him
and it won't take away one of the
pillars of the show like it's not like
trying to kill the green arrow off of
the green arrow TV show now there's also
a lot of theories about what's going to
happen to Barry I'll address that in a
second too but it's not like Barry is
going to leave the TV show permanently
that would be disastrous and it's still
disastrous if Joe West is the person who
winds up dying because Jesse Martin is
one of the best actors on the TV show
but the people that always hit the
chopping block first are the people who
aren't comic book characters who aren't
necessarily like the pillars of the TV
show like the flash himself or Wally
West iris West
Jay Garrick like the fundamental core
flash characters Joe West just isn't one
of those people he's just a really cool
character that they created for the TV
show that turned out to be really
amazing he's one of my favorite
characters so yeah you'll definitely be
upset if he dies but it won't kill the
show so everybody this season has
to pay a price there's no way around
that the reverse-flash explained that to
Barry during season 1 you can't change
time they'll always be something to
replace the thing that you change so
very creates flashpoint but it just
causes a bunch of new problems to
replace the ones that he tried to solve
so sabot R is killing someone this
season they can change that but a body
still needs to be dropped so really like
the easy way for iris West to still die
to be killed by sabot our infrared
cannot be iris West is for that to be a
hologram projected onto someone else so
unless they completely change the scene
and I don't think they will
we'll see somebody standing in for iris
West
it sounds like based on all the evidence
so far that that's probably going to be
Joe West but that's just a theory right
now so let me know who is your theory
about who is going to wind up dead at
the end of the flash season so there's
still a lot of episodes left this
plug-in to be some new flash footage for
the next episode this season and I know
a lot of you are wondering about the
future flash costume like when it's very
going to get the new version of the
costume well if you're wondering about
the next version of the costume that
they were creating this season that's
what this is they were creating the
future flash costume so I'm not
expecting Barry to wear a version of
this I think that they'll change the
costume just a little bit for season
four but you have to remember that this
is when the future newspaper date is
happening so this is many years in the
future but as we get closer to the
finale we can talk more about saboteurs
identity how Barry is going to defeat
him what the big twist is with his
character like how they're going to
leave things going into season 4 just
remember that most big villains even
zoom are fundamentally unkillable so
they could always come back in a future
season so whatever happens with sabotage
Barry will put them on ice in a way that
will not allow him to come right back in
the season 4 premiere but it won't be
the last you ever see of the character
but give me all your Flash finale
theories in the comments below just
remember that there's always lots of mr.
X but what's going to happen next is a
lot of you requested a Justice League
dark side villains video swelled to a
video explaining who some of his minions
are that will post it a couple hours
congratulations to rhymin you won the
flash ring giveaway from a couple videos
ago
please private message me so I can get
your contact details I'll announce the
next
winter the next time I post a flash
video so in case you missed any of it
you can click here for all the craziness
from this weekend Star Wars game of
Thrones that I posted make sure you
check everything out it was awesome and
you can click here for brand new flash
footage thank you so much for watching
let's high-five I'll see you guys in the
next video